afghanistan is a divided country the
taliban will need to unite
all the divided afghan leaders including
the office if they want to rule over and
stabilize the country after the kids of
war
the country is divided it's made up of
four major ethnic groups
it's like hazara pashtun tajik and all
of them have leaders and the leaders
literally need to be part of any talent
inclusive government in order to build a
strong and powerful future government
the taliban
[Music]
need to show
they are changed and unlike before
as they had imposed brutal laws on
people in 1990s when they were ruling
afghanistan they also need to show they
have capped all ties
with any type of terrorist groups
including al-qaeda
it is just a matter of time to prove
these things for the taliban
women rights are
another issue and the taliban now
insists on segregated university classes
and also they have told that they are
allowing women to get optic jobs this
can also help the taliban to get
international recognition
forming an inclusive government is
rather
relevant to show to the world that they
are in the process of forming an
inclusive government and that can help
the taliban to
get international legitimacy from
international community
[Music]
well the taliban have a terrible history
of mistreating women and depriving them
of their basic rights such as banning
them from schools or
getting public jobs
their brutal behaviors have not been
forgotten
the taliban need to show
their attitude towards woman has changed
but already we are seeing this group
insist on segregated university classes
and participation in employment only
under the terms of sharia law
the taliban will need to show it's not
violating human rights in order to get
international regulation and it has not
done that yet
afghanistan is an independent country
and cannot survive without financial
assistance from international donors
especially the united states which is
providing the majority of funding to the
afghanistan's
functioning
budget the u.s fed has frozen the
country's 9.5 billion dollars in assets
another other international
organizations such as world bank imf did
the same so lack of funding is another
major issue
facing the taliban
if the taliban cannot gain the
international recognition the taliban
won't be able to invite international
companies to extract the country's three
trillion dollars in mineral resources
islamic state has a presence in
afghanistan and it had conducted an
attack on kabul airport against the u.s
forces and afghan civilians which killed
tens of afghan civilians the taliban
says that islamic state is their enemy
and has always indicated they do not
they do not support its presence in
afghanistan the international community
will be relying on the taliban to show
it can contain the threat from the
islamic state but we don't know how it
will do that
and the attack on the airport shows how
vulnerable all afghans are under women's
rule
[Music]
you